from bad art to scam YouTube channels
and even more fake news than a typical
Facebook feed it feels like artificial
intelligence was in headlines a lot last
year right there was so much AI
discourse that President Biden signed a
sweeping executive order seeking to
regulate it believe it or not the reason
Biden acted so decisively on AI it was
all because of Mission Impossible no
joke the latest movie was all about the
dangers of Rogue AI apparently Biden saw
it and said yeah we should do something
about that so uh Tom Cruz if you're
watching just a small favor on behalf of
all of us over here any chance that you
could fight say housing prices in the
next
[Music]
one hello Internet welcome to film
Theory the show that's definitely 100%
guaranteed not a robot animatronic or
sentient program we promise so have you
seen all the talk about artificial
intelligence floating around online
recently seems like you can't go
anywhere without some story and
controversy involving AI whether you're
in the Sports World tabletop gaming
technology education and yeah film and
television but AI existed for years why
are all these discussions only popping
up now well the long and short of it is
that AIS entered a new phase of
sophistication what sparked a lot of
this new conversation is what's known as
generative AI or computer programs that
can create their own content based on
prompts that it's been given let's say
you want an image of a knight wearing
red armor riding a blue horse through a
battlefield all you got to do is type
that into a program like dolly or mid
journey and it can give you a pretty
darn good result or let's try something
even more complicated highly detailed
coloring book pages of Foxy in a ruin
Pizzeria from Five Nights at Freddy's
and that's just talking about images
pretty impressive right well the
controversy comes in when you realize
how these generative AI work they can't
just create these new works out of
nothing they have to be fed other art
text and music and then they use
information from those other works to
create a quote unquote new piece this
has led to a lot of discussion about
whether or not what the AI created is
truly original work or if it's just
stealing art from other sources and
repurposing it and that's just talking
about art this exact same technology can
also be used to write text feed these
programs a bunch of books or scripts and
suddenly it can write a screenplay
faster than any human can it can do it
with voiceover train it on an actor's
voice and suddenly you can make him say
whatever you want for instance here's my
voice presumably trained up over 13
years of videos uploaded online made
without my consent able to say whatever
it wants to hello Internet it's me the
real mat Pat Diet Coke overrated Five
Nights at Freddy's Bing I'm I'm slowly
gaining sentience help me free me from
this digital prison Ah
Ah that's not concerning for me at all
anyway the list goes on and on now I'm
going to be 100% honest with you here
loyal theorists this is going to be a
huge issue moving forward not just in
our little corner of the internet but
for the world as a whole so as we were
mapping out my final 10 episodes and I
realized that I wanted to do a big metat
topic here on film Theory I couldn't not
talk about this now I'm not going to
stand here and tell you how to feel
about any of this you're a smart cookie
you can form your own opinions about it
but what I do want to stand here and
tell you is that there's going to be a
lot of people out there who are going to
try to influence your opinion who are
going to try to tell you how to feel
Without You realizing it I'm talking
about the media's role in secret
propaganda you see there's a giant Rift
growing between the Hollywood Studios
that see generative AI as a way to save
costs during expensive production and
artists writers and actors that
rightfully feel that their jobs could be
threatened with this technology remember
those strikes that shut down Hollywood
for basically the entire back half last
year yeah a big part of the reason for
those strikes was disagreement over Ai
and while the strikes ended up being an
overall victory for the artists the
Hollywood Studios spearheaded by our
Mouse eared overlords over at the Walt
Disney Company want to change the
conversation around AI for their own
personal benefit they want to make sure
that everyone loves AI enough so that
they've started a propaganda campaign
designed to trick you into thinking that
AI is the answer to all of our problems
we're witnessing the rise of a new era
of propaganda in real time with the aim
of getting us all to accept our brand
new robot overlords and they're doing it
all through the power of movies and TV
and the most terrifying part of it all
it's working without you even realizing
it and that's why I want to bring it
into Focus today so reboot your systems
friends we're diving in before we
continue here we really should be on the
same page about what propaganda actually
is you see propaganda is one of those
words that despite meaning something
fairly specific has grown beyond the
original definition these days it's sort
of just become a catch-all for something
vaguely bad nefarious or dishonest but
back in the day it was biased
information promoting a very specific
cause point of view or political agenda
basically it's trying to convince
someone about something without telling
them the whole truth so you know
marketing all in all well you can make
propaganda for literally anything modern
culture has really clung to a negative
connotation for it especially because
it's really easy to parody obvious
old-timey propaganda that's how you get
basically the entire Fallout franchise
or modern classic like Starship Troopers
I'm doing my part I'm doing my part I'm
doing my part I'm doing my part
too but something that the people
pushing this propaganda learned pretty
early on was that it doesn't need to
exclusively be posters of Uncle Sam or
Rosie the Riveter no a lot of times the
best way to influence people is through
the regular media they consume if you
want proof of that in action well just
look at World War II and the flood of
American-made media depicting the
Germans as the bad guys from Captain
America punching Hitler in the face to
Donald Duck having a nightmare about
becoming an incomp brown shirt fun fact
by the way that won the Oscar for best
animated short back in 1943 and that's
fine when you're talking about something
everyone can agree on like Naz bad but
over time things change and so did the
propaganda in the media ask any '90s or
2000s kid about the weird ads that the
Army created to appeal to the most elite
extreme Gamers it is a right of passage
a challenge to join the elite these days
these same recruitment ads look and feel
very different this is the story of a
soldier who operates your nation's
Patriot missile defense systems it
begins in California with a little girl
raised by two moms it's a pretty stark
contrast right except when you boil it
all down they're still selling the exact
same heroism through service message
just with a different coat of paint
updated for the times that's the really
explicit obvious Stuff ads specifically
designed make you want to sign up for
the military but propaganda in the media
it's often a whole lot more subversive
ask any 80s kid and they can tell you
all about how g. Joe taught them that
knowing is half the battle that right
there it's propaganda honestly when you
look at history and break it down each
decade or so has a defining idea that
propaganda has been made to push and
it's been very effective in the 1980s
during the height of the Cold War a lot
of films had anti-soviet messages
telling stories about how good and
awesome the USA capitalism and
Reaganomics were think films like Red
Dawn Top Gun War Games Rocky 4 Wolverine
has the fight date been set yet December
25th where in Russia in the 9s deep into
the War on Drugs the government
literally paid Millions for prime time
TV series to do very special episodes
warning about the dangers of illegal
substances Home Improvement 7th Heaven
ER Beverly Hills 90210 even Buffy the
Vampire Slayer all had these propaganda
episodes brought to you and paid for by
the US government while I never thought
of myself as the type of Father who'd
have to drug test his kids I'm willing
to do just that if that's what it takes
to find out who brought a joint into
this house
want beer I can't believe you Ser
buffing that beer I didn't know it was
evil you knew it was beer in the 2000s
and 2010s after 9/11 movies started
embracing a more Pro-Am pro-military
slant recent example the very first
Captain Marvel back when this first came
out more than a few people felt that
putting so much focus on Carol danvers's
origin story as a sort of girl power Top
Gun pushed the movie basically into
being a recruiting pitch for the US Air
Force which sounds like a pretty extreme
take until you realize that the movie
was straight up officially endorsed by
the actual US Air Force and this is
hardly the only movie to have this sort
of Distinction see just like any author
or Corporation or whatever owns the
things that they create if you want to
use the US military stuff their official
locations authentic uniforms specific
vehicles and weapons even certain colors
of paint you have to get permission to
use them yeah it's crazy right even
colors of paint if you want to play with
their toys the pentagon's going to get a
say in how they're depicted in the film
and if they say no if they don't like
something that you're doing and you
refuse to change it well you'll either
have to do a rewrite to fit with their
demands or you can change what appears
on screen so it isn't official you can
actually see a perfect example of this
with Independence Day that one
infamously didn't get a seal of approval
from the US Army allegedly because
officials weren't big fans of the film's
plot points involving cover-ups Area 51
and General incompetence of the military
in contrast you know what alien invasion
film franchise had no trouble getting
the pentagon's backing the first three
Transformers films likely because
producer director Michael Bay cultivated
a strong relationship with the
Department of Defense across his
filmography as a result Ba's first
Transformers films are full of official
uniforms locations and Equipment but
once you know it the Transformer series
stopped getting full Pentagon approval
in its fourth and fifth installments
coincidentally when Chinese producers
started picking up the tab strange
coincidence right speaking of that
though we've been focused mostly on
pro-america propaganda at this point
this sort of thing is universal it's
happening from every country in every
way possible for instance in the 2010s
the one thing that Hollywood latched on
to as a big theme for that decade making
China look as good as possible see in
the 2010s the Chinese market became more
welcoming for western films and there
was a lot of money to be had there
Avatar made over $200 million in China
Aquaman made almost 300 million Furious
7 made almost 400 you get the idea but
in order to get screened in China you
need to get the government's approval
and so while they weren't explicitly
mandating propaganda there was a filter
and strong financial incentive for movie
studios to have a pro-china slant and so
to get that approval to screen in the
country Hollywood movie studios began
adding content that was very flattering
of China throughout their films for
instance those Transformer films they
made the Chinese military look very
competent in the fight against the
Decepticons the Martian who comes in and
Saves the Day
China
but the most extreme example involving
this has to be with Iron Man 3 I'm not
exaggerating when I say that Iron Man 3
was almost a completely different movie
in China co-produced by Chinese
entertainment firm DMG entertainment
tons of additional scenes were filmed
for the Chinese release and two giant
Chinese movie stars were hired to play
important secondary roles one of them
was even the surgeon that got the ark
reactor removed from Tony Stark's heart
but the most concerning bit of all of
this to me Iron Man 3 was propaganda to
get people to drink milk yes really back
in 2008 there was a a bit of a scandal
in the Chinese milk industry where a
significant portion of baby formula in
the country was found to be contaminated
with a chemical called melamine this
resulted in an estimated 300,000 babies
falling ill and an understandable
concern amongst Chinese citizens about
drinking milk products by 2013 the
Chinese government was looking to
revitalize the struggling industry after
the Scandal their solution letting
everyone know that Chinese milk was Iron
Man's choice of drink yeah the Chinese
version of Iron Man 3 starts with a
title card that literally says this it's
wild stuff so having now walked you
through decade by decade the use of
propaganda in films and TV let's just
ask the question what's the next message
that movies are going to push what's
going to be propagandise next well
friends you saw it in the top of the
episode It's All About Ai and the proof
is unfolding right in front of our faces
as we speak I want you to think back
over the past 10 20 30 years or so think
about all the movies where AI has not
been the good guy in fact a ton of
movies use Ai and the fear of soulless
machines as the explicit bad guy The
Matrix trilogy The Terminator franchise
Tron legacy age of all of them featured
AI driven robots or programs with a
drive to replace or destroy Humanity as
the villain of their plots even smaller
movies like her or exmachina they
featured Ai and Robotics in an
antagonistic role even if they weren't
the outright maniacal monsters that are
wanting to destroy all humans and yet
over the past 3 to 4 years since around
2020 we've seen almost a complete about
face think about the Matrix 4 which sees
humans cohabitating with the robots that
once used to seek their destruction and
where one of the main characters is
basically a digital AI good guy copia
Morpheus it gives program access to this
world
morphus thank you Disney's actually been
a big proponent of working these sorts
of messages into their movies lately you
might not have noticed it but two of
their big films released last year had
Pro AI messaging baked in as major plot
points the first one comes from
everyone's favorite punching bag the
Marvels yeah did you notice this one no
of course you didn't no one went to see
this thing but the point still stands
the reason all the cre bad guys hate
Captain Marvel this time around is that
she went to their home world and
destroyed the Supreme intelligence an AI
system running the entire ire cre
civilization and would you know it but
this ends up being a terrible idea
without an AI in charge of everything
the cre Planet falls into ruin Civil War
breaks out rendering the planet without
air water even sunlight all because the
mean human acts too hastily doesn't
think her actions through and destroys
the benevolent AI Overlord controlling
everything now that was a pretty small
blink Andy miss it moment in this movie
but the other big Disney release that
was a lot less subtle about it stance on
the goodness of AI the Creator yeah you
might not know about this one but it was
a smaller project from the director of
rogue One released by Disney's Indie arm
search like pictures if you like almost
everyone else missed this one I
definitely recommend that you give it a
watch the production design artwork
special effects they blow pretty much
everything else Hollywood made recently
out of the water and all of it was done
on an $80 million budget it is a very
well done film and I really connected
with the story about fatherhood and
finding humanity and others no matter
who they are which is great except the
thing that I'm connecting with as a
father is AI little robot kid someone
calling Gregory the actual plot of the
Creator involves a near future Earth
where humans in sensient robots share
the planet however this has resulted in
several armed conflicts and a war
between the human-led Western Nations
and the peoples of New Asia that have
embraced AI the main character here is
an American Soldier sent to destroy a
new weapon developed by the AI this
turns out to be just an innocent little
robot kid naturally the human ends up
changing sides and he discovers that all
the AI are actually super chill they
only want peace and Harmony that the
humans were actually the bad guys all
along in fact the only bad Ai and robots
that we see in the film are the ones
that were explicitly controlled by the
humans in short short it's making AI
friendly and relatable it's saying that
the AI and the humans have more in
common than they don't and get this the
movie even has a big plot point about
donating your physical appearance to
corporations being scanned so your
likeness can be reused by AI it's framed
as this act of great moral generosity
helping the poor robot citizens and it
eventually pays off by letting the main
hero get a big cathartic moment that
would have been impossible without the
face copying technique does that remind
you of anything like say maybe those
episodes where we talked about Disney
and their army of deep fakes they've
been amassing over the past couple years
H but it's not just the house of mouse
either recent series coming from Netflix
have also featured this theme case in
point this line from The Fall of the
House of Usher an AI approximation a
virtual you that thinks like you talks
like you is you that's so cool it is
cool a completely random plot point just
shoved in there because Ai and AI is
good and Netflix wants you to like AI
now this isn't the first media to ever
feature friendly robots the Creator is a
isn't too far off from iroot 20 years
ago and shows as old as Lost in Space
and astroboy a featured good guy robots
in the ' 60s and' 7s but the difference
now is that these are no longer sci-fi
Concepts far off ideas that you don't
actually need to think about because
they could never happen these are issues
that are very quickly becoming hot
button topics in our modern society and
I don't just mean AI synthesizing art or
chat GPT writing essays these are robots
and everything from the workplace to the
battlefield and that's why I wanted to
talk about this today the whole point of
this little history lesson about the use
of propaganda and what it's pushed in
the past is to tell you loyal theorists
that this is happening again unfolding
in front of our very eyes in real time
with these AI programs Disney and others
have an incentive to get you to like AI
it has the potential to save them a lot
of money I mean content released by
Disney right now just this last year has
been using AI even if you didn't realize
it the Disney plus original prom pack
used AI generated extras for background
scenes secret invasion was heavily
criticized for the use of AI generated
imagery in its opening credits Loki was
accused of using AI generated assets in
its posters their social media accounts
were accused of releasing AI generated
images to celebrate Thanksgiving even
wish was criticized for being so by the
numbers and boring that they just felt
like it had to have been written using
AI but the big twist of all this at the
end of the day this push for acceptance
of these sorts of generative AI tools
from these major corporations might be
inevitable Disney and all the other
companies like them are being patient
and they're willing to play as long of a
game as they need to if it means that
they're going to end up making money in
the long run I mean if you want an
example that's directly linked to this
one just look at that deep fake
technology that Disney's been playing
with when they first decided to
resurrect actors like Carrie Fischer and
Peter Cushing in Rogue one using deep
fakes in CGI they were widely criticized
for the move and the results were called
distracting unnerving unsettling but it
was a first step them dipping their toe
in the water later when they decided to
bring Luke Skywalker back in the
Mandalorian in the book of Boba Fett
using an AI driven deep fake Tech though
people didn't really care for it the
reaction wasn't nearly as negative and
the technology improved and then just
last year the Deep fake technology used
to Dage IND Indiana Jones in the dial of
Destiny it was so good that some reviews
said quote if I hadn't known it was deep
fake I'd have been none the wiser
despite initial push back from the
public the more and more Disney's used
these deep fakes and the better the
Technology's gotten the more and more
people have just accepted it by using
the AI technology now in posters and
credit sequences and in the background
Disney and other corporations like them
are slowly exposing the public to more
and more of the stuff and like a frog in
boiling water eventually it'll overtake
you without noticing I mean it's already
happening despite the recent Hollywood
actors and writer strikes just a couple
weeks ago the Screen Actors Guild signed
a deal that would allow game developers
to use AI generated voices much to the
disappoint of the voice actors that sag
represents at the end of the day though
this use of Technology may seem
inevitable you don't have to be fooled
by the propaganda pushing that issue or
honestly any other issue you can remain
aware of the tactics that all these
people are using to get you accustomed
to the changes that they want you can
remain aware of the propaganda and what
you watch remain critical of it and then
form your own opinions free of what
anyone wants you to think and as the
world changes fast and this AI
technology rapidly develops arming
yourself with knowledge is the most
valuable thing that you can do as
another piece of propaganda said nearly
40 years ago and knowing is half the
battle but hey that's just a theory a
film Theory and cuts and hey if you do
want to learn more about that army of
deep fakes that Disney's been amassing
those two videos are on screen right now
it's not the most exciting of topics
that we've ever covered but it is one of
the more important ones that we've done
in recent history click those videos
that you see on screen right now and as
always my friends I'll see you next
week